[Music]
tis the season to say i do cities
gearing up for one of the biggest
wedding booms post pandemic a lot of
people had a reschedule right according
to the washington post 2.6 million
ceremonies will take place this year
nationwide that's half a million more
than average and one of this year's most
popular trends doesn't have anything to
do with decorations
we're going to have more weddings this
year than any other year in history and
one of the best parts for newlyweds is
the new bling they get to wear around
their finger from glitz and glamour
things like clarity cuts and carrots all
things to consider before making the big
purchase millennials are typically
buying making this purchase before they
buy a house dustin lemmek is the founder
and ceo of brightco a specialty
insurance company right now he's seeing
a big trend in the two stone custom
engagement rings thanks to celebrities
like megan fox and machine gun kelly who
designed this one for her custom has
become much larger for engagement rings
so like basically if you can dream it
like it can be created this is
literally two stones and people are
having a lot of fun with it so you're
seeing a lot of times multiple different
types of stones so you'll see like a
diamond paired with a sapphire or
you'll see a diamond paired with a
colored diamond like a pink stone
um
different shapes in combination in sharp
contrast to that super modern style
vintage and antique is also trending
vintage jewelers who are specializing in
um reconditioned
like you know 1950s rings
with kind of these older diamond cuts
um or sometimes you'll see the mounting
like a vintage mounting with a newer
diamond
a recent consumer survey shows sixty
percent of people pay between twenty
five hundred and ten thousand dollars
for an engagement ring with only fifty
five percent buying insurance lemick
says it costs a fraction of the price to
protect the ring from damage or loss at
bryco for instance for a ten thousand
dollar ring cost between fifty and
hundred dollars annually